c'est la parole en état mafieux damien
abad
merci beaucoup monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
les déclarations tragi comique sur fidel
castro et le régime de cuba de votre
désormais ministre de l'écologie sont le
symbole de la déliquescence d'un pouvoir
socialiste à la dérive à les rendre
hommage à fidel castro est déjà en soi
une faute de goût qu'aucun autre pays
européen que la france n'a commises à
l'exception de la grèce mais au lieu de
faire plus bas à madame la ministre vous
avez un sens et le régime de l'un des
derniers dictats stalinien contre toute
évidence et en toute indécence cette
faute de goût s'est transformé en faute
morale car vous avez trahi la mémoire de
l'oppression des victimes de
l'oppression du régime cubain
cette faute morale est aussi une faute
politique parce que vous avez fouet la
parole de la france entraînant des
propos complaisants sur cette dictature
comment pouvez-vous prétendre qu'il y à
de la désinformation sur la réalité des
droits de l'homme à cuba quand on sait
qu'ils iraient une la censure et la
répression
que dites vous à ces centaines de
prisonniers politiques
comment pouvez vous déclarez cubains ont
une liberté religieuse et de conscience
alors même qu amnesty international
dresse un bilan accablant sur les
libertés fondamentales
madame
madame la ministre la castre itude aigüs
à ce soit
et contrairement à ce que vous avez
déclaré ce n'est pas la polémique qui
est déplacé ce sont vos propos qui sont
déplacés madame la ministre vous avez
tenu ces propos au nom du gouvernement
valls
ma question est simple monsieur le
premier ministre la confirmation dans
ses fonctions de manuel royal signifie
tels que le président de la république
et vous même approuvé ces déclarations
scandaleuses qui abîment encore un peu
plus l'image de la france à
l'international si la parole est à mme
haddad ségolène royal ministre de
l'environnement de l'énergie et de la
mer si on écoute sa réponse s'il vous
plaît c'est le président monsieur le
député s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
voyez je peux répondre un peu de liberté
d'expression si vous me laissez répondre
comme à cuba
monsieur cochet monsieur cochet écoutons
la réponse de la ministre
s'il vous plaît allez on écoute
on écoute
monsieur le député je vous remercie de
votre question qui va me permettre de
répondre à cette polémique est pas voulu
ni pu jusqu'à présent y répondre parce
que je respecte le temps des funérailles
auxquelles je me suis rendu et pour
lesquels des centaines de milliers de
cubains se sont rassemblés et s'il vous
plaît je ne vous cache pas que la
violence de ces polémiques m'ont
surprise et en blesser les cubains je me
suis comme je les dis je le répète c'est
aux historiens de faire le bilan de
cette histoire avec les ombres et les
lieux m je me suis exprimé sur la
situation actuelle d'un pays die
magnifique et d'un pays courageux qui
est en train de s'ouvrir et qui reçoit 4
millions de visiteurs et de touristes
par an n'avaient pas dire que 4 millions
de personnes se rendent dans une
dictature ce n'est pas vrai monsieur le
député je voudrais dire également que
nous avons aujourd hui genou plus
accompagner l'ouverture d'un pays et
vous mes grandes entreprises françaises
qui ont été consternés que le l'onda
recettes
ou alors il faudra m'expliquer monsieur
le député pourquoi vous n'agresser pas
de la même façon le papa qui s'est rendu
deux fois à cuba et qui a rencontré
personnellement fidel castro ses deux
prédécesseurs
s'il vous plaît allez sur un cuba s'il
vous plaît c'est quand je relève
d'ailleurs l'ambassadeur de france à
cuba nommé par nicolas sarkozy en 2010 à
glaris ceux ci il n'y a plus de
condamnés détenus pour motifs politiques
et qu'il fallait cesser de caricaturer
cuba actuellement alors je vous en prie
construisons positivement à l'avenir de
ce pays et des relations entre la france
et cuba et entre l'union européenne et
cuba puisque le 14 décembre prochain
sera signé un accord de coopération
entre l'union européenne et cuba et je
me réjouis profondément car qui merci